and I can't figure out if I should put
my hat on or hat off you ever have that
and women y'all are lucky unless it's a
like a you know kind of a women that do
tennis or a lesbian type of lady that
likes to wear a mint like a hat then you
don't have to regularly decide hat or no
hat hat or no hat a lot of stuff goes
into that when you're a fella when
you're a man you know when you're an
adult male because it's a matter like
okay dudes my hair do my hair look nice
enough today or do I just hide that [ __ ]
you know just be a a headed actor you
feel me I had a Potamus
you know do you or do you say look I'm a
ride with the with the Lord's drapes
today and let your hair go you know I'm
gonna do that thing a little I'm gonna
do that dangle and let your hair go and
my look there are days when I feel like
I'm losing hair like I woke up the
morning in the morning I'm down maybe 70
hairs or down maybe 6,800 hair or a
hundred two hundred hairs now I say dang
whoa I'm doing hat today and there's
those days when I wake up and I'm
feeling full like my hair like a like
maybe my hair had other hair stay
overnight and sleep at the house and so
suddenly my head looks full of hair you
know like it's like a family reunion or
something
four follicles let's get into the
episode
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wandering how could I be so far oh and
my mind is somewhere else but when I
found it I'll patch up where it's been
grown now I'm just on the breeze and not
feeling like these leaves I must be it's
gonna take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake
[Music]
Wow thank you hello hello everyone I'm
coming to you it is Monday May 6 in a
year 2001 92019 we're calling it our to
zero one nine for people that just do
individual numbers but still keep time
and this is it this is where we are you
know this is where we are this is where
I am that's what I'm realizing a little
bit today this is where I am you know
some time and I don't like making a
decision man
this hat thing I couldn't do I go hat do
I go no hat and then I started thinking
at least men we have that option
you got that get out of you got that get
out of a if your hair looks if your hair
is looking a little ugly and I'm where
you got that get out of ugly free card
that hat you put the hat on a hat is
just a small apartment for your head
once you get inside a hat it's almost
like being indoors a little bit and
that's what I'll I've always enjoyed the
most about a hat is that you put a hat
on and suddenly it's like you're indoors
a little bit it's like you got a little
you know like um you got a little more a
little more between you in the world you
got a little bit of you know I like
being a little bit more comforted I'm
that comforted cat some cats you see
them up there on the powerlines walking
the powerlines and doing a cigarettes
and um you know maybe they uh they'll
get their tail cornrowed and they're out
there and [ __ ] you know doing dice
and [ __ ] like that and hanging out you
know out in Philadelphia or different
places you know but I'm that comfort cat
I like to have a little bit of a hat on
sometimes you know I like to put you
know sometimes I'll put a little bit of
cotton in my shirt I'll empty a bag of
cotton into my shirt so people can't see
it out here but I'm comforted I got that
extra go on happening I got that out you
know you know I got that I got that that
fluff inside of me just just I need a
little bit more comfort you know
sometime I used to have a neighbor and
he was a real real big guy and they
called him his name was Wayne but they
called him fat Wayne I didn't call him
that his dad did actually but and uh I'd
sleep over at his house sometimes and
we'd sleep in his bed we was lay in his
bed you know because he lived there and
he had it and that's where he kept his
bed obviously and we would lay in his
bed and when he fell asleep you couldn't
wake him up
you thought he was dead until he woke up
and he may have been dead he may not
even have actually gone to sleep at
night he may have died and then just
just risen every morning you know maybe
he just had those religious you know he
just zoned out and then rezone back in
but he would win so and he would fall
asleep it you know you could you could
put things on his back you could do um
you know you could play soldiers on his
back and do little you know the army
coming up over here up over to uh you
know the scapula and the other you know
you could do fighters you know Rambo
versus you know sheera and and you could
do different stuff like that on his back
you know you could do whatever but I
remember when I would go to when I would
be time for bed I would lay down next to
him and I put his arm over me in his arm
like a tattoo on it or something I
remember what it was let me think about
now what was that it may have been a
couple long but was a snowman or
something some bacon and his own and I'd
put his arm over me I'd put his arm over
me and then that's how I would sleep you
know I'm just that comfort cat you know
I'm just that comfort cat man I like to
have a little bit of extra I like to
have a little bit I need a little more
support you know I'm the kind of guy
you'll find a training wheel on my back
just one just that one hitter you know
I'm the kind of guy who uh who if I lay
down next to you already I'll throw your
arm over me you know for a little while
now I you know I'll share I'll do you
for a while to us you know once I get a
little rest I'll wake up and I'll throw
one of my arms over you or to arms
because I got a lean medium arms I got
these medium reaches I can't even if
somebody with really short arms wants to
shake my hand I can't get there you know
other than medium arms but I'll put both
of them on you so you feel a little bit
of comfort as well because I know what
it feels like you know I know what it
feels like not only do I recognize that
I need comfort but then I have to then
also do the inverse of that I got to
recognize what it feels like if somebody
else needs comfort because I have to
notice that like if there's something
that I that I have a that that I that I
require then there's going to be
something that somebody else then
there's then I should notice that same
requirement or deficiency and others
immediately you know and that's really
been something that has been brought to
some of the forefront of my life over
the past couple years since I started
trying to get into like 12-step and
learning about things is that
is some of that awareness just realize I
know just how common it is when i have
an issue that somebody else have it that
i can notice that issue in them and not
accuse them of having it i don't have to
say it but I could recognize man I know
you know I recognize this person they
might I can try to just show them extra
comfort I'll just take a gamble that
they need more comfort but I am that uh
mm-hmm okay all right whose was that
water Jesus I am I can be that comfort
cat thank you guys for being here today
I did put a hat on for those you listen
over audio
I am happy I'm happy to be here man I'm
gonna put a picture up on Instagram I
can't even tell you some of the nice you
know people always bring nice things to
some of the comedies there's not always
you know for 14 years nobody brought
nobody brought it you think to the
comedy shows but some people brought
some a couple of nice gifts this week
and there's always like not see you know
that's not always but there's sometimes
nice cards and just really sweet
messages and you know I wish I had a ton
of time enough time to just I have time
to to read them and enjoy him always had
time to discuss all of them but some
really cool art and and some other nice
things man over there in in in New York
City at the shows first I want to
announce I know everybody in Europe has
been hitting me up which sounds like the
craziest thing ever because we might be
coming back to Europe I want to say that
you know but I want to tell you these
these uh presale this is some European
tour dates and these people have been
waiting for a long time and and thank
you so much so many like just nice
messages from Ireland and Norway sweat
and bra from the UK you know and these
are the places I'm going some of these I
picked some of these were presented to
me but whatever doesn't matter they go
on sale on Tuesday at 10 o'clock a local
time European time so don't hit you know
don't be hitting
me up immediately when you hear this
podcast and say I don't see the tickets
well look at your clock look at your
calendar bro if you do it like that
I mean I know some people wake up and
guess what day it is
if you do that then don't [ __ ] then do
not bother me but if you wake up any and
look at a calendar and you got that time
the clock peace ok the 2-handed don't
[ __ ] roll with that one-handed thing
shady I remember when I was like 9 years
old they came out like a one-hand clock
sir everybody just [ __ ] a little bit
earlier a little bit late night you know
people furious people were furious you
know I remember that they had a wig shop
in our town it didn't know exactly when
to open and the lady ended up and it
upon us and committing suicide and I
don't know if it was because of that but
you know you got to think if somebody's
already wearing a wig they just they
they you know they you know it's
touching go for him so suddenly you you
know somebody comes out with a
one-handed clock and people just have to
guess how many minutes are going on in
this it's just a lot but anyhow these
are the dates uh 9 September October
September 13th in Glasgow at the o2
Academy September 15th in Dublin Ireland
and a vicar street of a car street we
got two shows there November September
18th Oslo Norway at folketeatret
folketeatret Oh folk theater folk
theatre oh okay
and then oh and that's 918 917 Stockholm
Sweden at China tea a turn
China Teheran 920 and 921 at London
London UK London UK at Shepherds Bush
over there and that's gonna be we got
some shows everything that's four shows
922 in this um Manchester UK and that's
dancehall show number one and then 924
2019 Amsterdam Netherlands at the mirror
art I think that's how you say that the
MIR Vaart and Damir of art dude that's
when I mean that's an old thing I
remember when we was young somebody told
us you could uh I guess it's a little
profane let me just say I'm excited
oh also the presale code for those dates
that the code is onward onw ard and that
and that's the only way you can get
those tickets on presale is the code
onward that way that only
tpw listeners can get them and are just
people that are in our world you know
I'll put a post out on social medias as
well and and only people that can that
are in our world can get them so we get
first shot at it so that's why they have
that presale code because I said to the
man the man said we want to do presale
code I said what do we do about that
I said everybody have to remember a
magical word to get something you know
where are we I mean is this are we in a
fable are we in a you know are we in you
know Rumpelstiltskin why does somebody
have to remember a magical word to get
something is this the bridge to
terabithia but it so I'm saying that
that's why the presale code it makes you
sure you can access the tickets and that
ends on Friday at 10:00 a.m. local time
in Europe European time and uh and so
that's it those are they starts Tuesday
and goes to Friday and the code is on
word and thank you guys so much for your
support I'm really man I'm nervous
because I hike
it's a you know there's nothing there's
nothing scarier to me then going onto a
stage where you don't know if people are
gonna get the way the joke is the jokes
of the humor or whatever and you have to
tell the jokes because I tell stories
man if you mean on the beginning of a
story eating just gonna pop in about
seven minutes into that bastard
so but I'm grateful and I'm happy to be
going there and I'm happy that you that
you guys will be there and uh and thank
you so much for everybody the support
man so many people have bought in
tickets to this to the shows around the
u.s. and I'm so grateful man I'm I'm
gonna take some time off for myself here
in the next couple of weeks and do less
some less this past weekend's we'll have
some and we got trickling Mickey coming
in everybody knows him he's cystic
fibrosis survivor and we you know you
know it was I was fortunate enough to
meet him we were we were fortunate
enough to meet him uh I think maybe nine
months before when he was on transplant
list and then he got them new hitters
you know he got them new Huff Huff
nutsacks and it was chest about one year
ago so we're celebrating the one-year
anniversary by having trickle on Mickey
in here and he's got those new [ __ ]
baby bags you know them new whistle
makers he's got new lungs somebody died
and he got the lungs man you know
somebody died and now and now Nikki you
know Mickey's playing the [ __ ] bat
you know
Mickey's playing somebody else's
bagpipes but that's the system that's
how it goes well that leads me into this
man I'll say this support for this past
weekend comes from manscaped who is
number one in men's below the belt
grooming manscaped offers precision
engineered tools from manscaping with
the right tool for the job and manscape
and i got their package they got that
2.0 kit it features that lawn mower
trimmer with that skin safe technology
and they got them tool where you could
really just you know you could unjoin
key a jump and unfuck you skunk
it's 100% waterproof there
shock-resistant this trimmer won't Nick
or snag your nuts shut out the premature
Nick our producer your balls will thank
you and you can get 20% off that
manscaped if it's Mother's Day but your
father's kind of a little bit of a [ __ ]
then get him this happy Mother's Day hey
Dad 20% off free shipping and a free
travel bag with code Theo at manscaped
comm that's 20% off with free shipping
and a free travel bag at manscaped calm
and use code Theo but mere Vaart man we
used to do so somebody told me when I
was young you know I remember when I was
a kid somebody told us that if you
there's a little bit grotesque and I'm
sorry to get like this I know it's it
could be morning you're listening if you
fight you know if you did body gasp if
you did gas out of your body out of your
butt then on a mirror that you could see
it you know that in regular if you just
you know did body gas out under the air
you can't see it you know you could
obviously it has a you know of mostly
violent scent
every now you know every maybe mm body
gasses you'll get one that's really
you're like damn they should you know
make a good candle out of that one
that's you know I'm something you know
things are going well but the other 1999
attempts at body gas you get something
naughty you know you get that you know
you just get that booty ghost that's out
there that's haunting people's senses
but someone had told us Herman when I
was a kid someone told us so maybe they
just wrote it on the sidewalk with a
knife but that if you you know did body
gas on a mirror if you were sitting on a
mirror or near a mirror like with your
butt up you know stood in on the sink
with your butt against the mirror and
you did a gas that you could see it then
it would take a you know as if it was a
ghost or something I guess that's how we
thought oh I could see it I could see
what
you know and so that was it man we'd sit
on these mirrors you know we got a
couple mirrors they had a um her old
lady that lived I mean everybody had
this old lady that lived we had an old
little part about two and a blocks away
and her house I think burned down at
some point I mean that usually happens
with a lot of those older women but
before it happened we'd go over there
and she would give us a you know a
couple dimes or whatever to water the
plants and do this and that you know
look for the cats and I'll tell you this
honestly man um she she all you know she
she only had probably two cats but she
paid us to find about nine cats so we'd
take one of the cats bring it in there
show it to her she would you know say
its name and pet it then then it would
we'd let it go and say okay we're gonna
find the other one
and then we'd go find the same the you
know they only had two so we find the
other one bring it in and just keep
going back and forth until she thought
she'd seen them all but really it was
just two cats who were psyched you know
we were you know the old the old cat you
know cats which game well so we got you
know we so next thing you know we showed
her all the cats we got these dimes or
whatever but anyway she had some nice
mirrors so I know we'd be over there and
once you got the cat's out of the way
she we could hang out in her house she
didn't even know we're in there you know
we'd climb on the shelves and you know
look at books or whatever look at little
trinkets and this and that and she had
nice drawers heavy wood and you pull
open a heavy wood drawing you smell
would you know and it was it just had a
different experience you know being over
there you know all of her stuff felt
kind of old and mysterious bruh you know
felt like you could just open up a can
of peas or a can of carrots at her house
and a and a damn spirit would pop out it
had that kind of that kind of momentum
was just built into the environment well
anyway so I don't know if I can tell um
I went on talking
oh so she had these nice mirrors big
ones if we could set on the floor take
them off the wall set them on the floor
and you do body you sit on there with
your butt out do body gas and look for
the ghost you know but we never saw
anything you know we never saw I mean
people would lie and say they saw
somebody nobody ever saw anything man
but that reminds me of that mirror of
art and that's at de Mir Vaart in
Amsterdam Netherlands and that's
September 24th and that's that but yeah
thank everybody so much man I'm
overwhelmed at uh you know the amount of
support people that are gonna come out
and see the show is just you know man it
just really feels like a dream come true
in a lot of ways so thank you thank you
very very much
to everyone and when they came out of
New York City this weekend I mean it was
a wild time I mean Carl Lentz past
popped through the pasture and he's
gonna come and be a guest at some point
we had a father-son pair that came
through that it you know they drove from
about two hours we have people that
drove from Vermont people that drove
from Delaware people that drove down
from Canada and came in we had a young
man I'll put this thing on my minister I
mean me a beautiful skateboard like
Beyonce you know like that you know and
they had I mean just some really nice
gifts somebody gave me a Darryl
Strawberry book really cool and then a
taxi because everybody knows I do that
story but let me get into a little bit
of this episode man while I still have
my hat on and while I'm still feeling
you know you know like I'm that comfort
cat Oh a lot of cats in this episode
just realize that yeah man we go to a
lady's house and you know what I wonder
in hindsight maybe she knew that she
only had two cats
you know maybe she knew maybe we thought
that she didn't have the awareness but
she did and so that way we just got to
spend more time over there and we gave
us something to do maybe she knew we
didn't have much to do you know and she
would do that you know and I remember -
I remember now actually she spent it she
split I split of candidum Frank and I we
nurse you know he's to have these cans
being and wieners they used to have
these cans called being and wieners and
it was a can of beans and wiener and
they cut up half a wiener in there and
it looked like they cut the Wiener with
a spoon because the edges of the wiener
cut they weren't straight there were
those uh convex them convex cut so you
get that wiener that you know usually
you get a cut of wiener it's you know
it's the the width of the wing and then
it's that where the cuts are then chops
but on these big
we we need we beam we invaders on these
weening [ __ ] they had um the cut the
the cuts on the wiener were you know
convex or something like you're trying
to see the moon you know through glass
but the well but she would cut open a
can of those and we'd have them over
there
me and little Daniel be over there
having a man and I'll tell you this
about Daniel man people forget about him
and don't want to think about him knew
Daniel was up to no good man most of the
time but I'll say this a lot of times
they had rumors going around this is
back when rumors was really the most
popular way to know about stuff and
these days thanks to all the you know
mainstream media being a bunch of dog
[ __ ] it's welcome back rumors so the UM
you know Daniel would get in there and
he uh he would eat the wing he'd you
know he'd always steal a chunk of my
wing
out of the UH out of my being wieners
you know and and and in hindsight I
remember a couple times he got sick
because he he stole that chunk see
there's just two sides this there's two
sides to everything you know he stole
that chunk and he got sick and I didn't
get sick because I would just wait to
see how he did how he fared after that
chunk of Frank and then I would just
being around them if he look like he was
getting real sweaty halfway into his own
bowl I say damn I'm but you know you
know you know you've heard of Frank
Sinatra well I'm saying sayonara Frank's
because I'm saying bye-bye to these
Frank chunks to these you know wean
these wean cuts and I wouldn't have him
because look Daniel be over there
sweating dude and when he sweat is shirt
he he had this like uh I guess his shirt
where he had maybe one of those
constricting shirts so when he got real
sweaty his shirt would get even smaller
but let's get into a couple of calls man
those European dates are out thank you
know so much um a lot of people have
called in last week I was talking about
you know father-son relationship and uh
man I got so many nice responses and
messages and you just wanted to say
thank you just thanks for you know just
thanks for not judging me while I think
about stuff you know I appreciate that
like you know that's why I'm like
sometimes it's hard to be in this world
I think for a lot of us because we
created an environment we didn't the
dark arts created an environment where
we can't even think or feel or share
sometimes without being judged you know
and I'm not saying that I don't do that
sometimes we all do it but I'll be
damned if some if there's people out
there making a business out of it man it
makes me mad so but maybe inadvertently
I do you know like I we never know what
we do sometimes until we figure it out
but but I just want to say I get a lot
of nice just people that can relate
people that are sharing their own
stories with me and it just makes me
feel and then when I hear somebody
else's story or they're sharing
something man it makes me feel like a
human because it makes me feel wow you
know I have feelings I care about what
this person saying I have feelings man
it reminds me it reminds me that I have
feelings because of feelings man that's
you know the sugar lizard goes for
whatever but whatever that other animal
is that feeling animal he's more like a
sloth you know he's cz you know he's
around the surface man but he gets
scared to kind of peek around sometime
maybe he is like a cat
maybe that feeling line or that feline
that feel line yeah that's what it is
man so if I don't go with that sugar
lizard then I can gaga I can be patient
and I can have a little bit of that
feline feel what choice I make not just
not just that sugar lizard get whatever
what is that a snicker titty whatever
you got to be where that sugar lizard
that first thing and that's who all
these advertisers and all these you know
all those Bulls outs are they selling -
they selling of that sugar lizard oh you
got a dime let me set that right over
there what's that a Twinkie
was that a nipple was that a fake uh you
know uh fake net you know if neck
installment or whatever fake titty they
sell you all of that set it right there
that's what you need get that let that
sugar lizard bites whatever first thing
out there
you when you when you let that when you
wedges wait don't shoot don't don't
don't sugar you can sugar you can feel
the sugar don't lizard
don't let that [ __ ] a little reptile
rep don't let them rep you I wait back I
try and way back let that feel line what
do I feel what do I really need to do
for me right now to be okay would one
really need to do right now to be okay
to really be okay in that feel I'm and I
notice whenever you know people come up
and are except in and you know share
night or just you know I'm just grateful
to have an environment here where we can
share stuff and not feel judged and
maybe there are people out there to
judge and sometimes look man I'll be the
first to tell you sometimes I'm a real
Posse you know sometimes I'm Way too
caught up in my feelings and I can't get
out of it you knowing that look that's
where I am right now but I also you know
I mean I try to I try to be out there
and get past some of this stuff and I
feel a lot better than I used to you
know I got a lot more tools but every
now and then your feelings flare up and
that's okay I mean some time we go
through episodes won't even talk about
anything like that but uh but I just
want to say I'm grateful to have that
sort of environment here where people
don't always just sugarless at all look
at this love yeah they're talking about
us failing to God
because I think we have a world that
don't let us feel enough that don't let
us explore enough you know that don't
let us just be brave to share and to say
you know and we don't do that here you
know we don't I mean I hear this in a
lot of different rooms but we don't hear
we don't we don't we don't kill our
wounded this ain't Hollywood whatever I
don't know what I'm talking about now
I'm just getting weird okay let's get
into a couple of calls man thank you
guys so much for the calls thank you
guys so much for hitting the hotline as
always nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three a lot of cities have new
tickets that one on sale for the regular
shows so you could check your city
I think Vancouver has a new show now on
Wednesday night up there Austin we added
a show I believe Sacramento we added a
show so there's other shows in the in
the u.s. that have new ones so thank you
so much for your support
and I want to thank actually right now
you know all our patreon errs sorry I
feel like I'm talking too much
someone let us get kind of going and I
feel like I'm talking too much sometimes
you know the people that support our
patreon or that's how we are able to do
nice things for the single moms and get
that cash where we hide the you know we
hide money in the hotel room for the
cleaning ladies and and those things are
on the YouTube but that's what our
patreon goes to you know our patreon
isn't really big a lot of people run
their whole you know podcast off their
patreon we don't do that here you know
and not that and that's okay no shade on
anybody's uh but how we find things to
do you know outreach and stuff is
through our patreon and I just want to
say that we are going to reach out to
all the single moms that we have that
we've brought out to shows over the past
year year and a half and we're going to
send all of them some flowers so I just
thought of that but
but we're gonna do that so that's
something our patrons gonna do so if you
are a patreon supporter just know that
already this weekend you bought flowers
for about twelve different single moms
around America and in the cards they
don't say that this from me to said this
from us and so I hope you feel good
about that because I do you know I do
you know it's thinking the other day
that when we look at our mother and I've
been on my mind a lot when we look at
our mom when if you or if you're raised
by a single parent as a child you look
at that parent and you hold them
accountable for motherly stuff oh and
fatherly stuff you don't even realize it
because you need it all you need it all
as a child and we hold that we hold our
mom accountable for fatherly ways and
not only that but then the mother also
has to be a father and it gets really
jumbly man for me it did anyway you know
I'm sorry for me it got jumbly and only
now am I able to kind of look through
some of that and and start to be able to
sort it out and wonder well why do i why
this and why that you know him I hold my
mother accountable for things that that
a father should have been there for him
I hold my father for things that a
mother should have been there for and
not even knowing not even realizing it
but Mother's Day is a great opportunity
to reconnect with somebody that you care
about so from our talk from me to all
the single moms out there we love you
guys and thank you for all the hard work
that you do and we know it's not easy
sometimes you know I can only imagine if
your husband or something whoever who
created this child with you left you and
men to you know if whoever created that
child with you left and left you to care
about them man there's got to be a an
anger there and angst you know that man
they didn't even care about it enough
about you to stay in this they didn't
care enough about the child to really
stay in it or to help and then you have
to be even stronger and not tell the kid
that you can't you can't bat you can't
really bastardize
that other parent because it's so I'm
sure just a lot of levels going on I'm
not in that space but I can only imagine
what it's like you know but man what a
beautiful job what else oh so I got a
couple patreon questions that came in so
these are Victor s Johnson ii asked in a
previous episode you mentioned you don't
feel a sense of community out in los
angeles has that changed at all you know
what
since podcasting it has changed i've
kind of built my own community a little
bit or not we've built a community and
also since I got into 12-step programs
since I got into that sort of thing for
me I have much more of a sense of
community
I have people every day now that I can
call and reach out to that are reaching
out to me you know I have meetings that
I go to or I meet up with others so
there has been a sense of community
there at the Comedy Store that's become
a sense of community it's just taking a
lot longer to find and I do think also
that uh la to me just feels more and
more like an airport it feels like like
an International Airport even all the
way from when you leave when you leave
the airport at LAX it still feels like
an airport like the whole time I'm here
whether I'm at home that work wherever
it all feels like a big extension of the
airport so you know that feeling you
have when you're in an airport you know
you're sick people are passing you're
seeing them here oh yeah let's do this
let's say and then it but everybody's
just taking off everybody's coming back
or taking that's what la always feels
like to me everywhere so I think within
that space that's hard to have a sense
of community when there's just so much
motion going on but I'm grateful you
know guy I got guys like Brendan Schaub
I got producer Nick you know I got
little Johnny who's uh you know the
you know the movie star twink he's you
know we just got you know there's a
group that I have yeah so it's gotten
better that's the short answer but thank
you for the question that's from our
patreon supporter victor johnson let me
see what else on helper des said your
comedy is always so creatively
descriptive have you ever written any
short stories or things that aren't
comedy yeah yeah i have you know you
know try to get some books published
over the years I haven't tried in a
while
just about growing up you know one
fiction one nonfiction one just like
growing up and just how fear kind of ran
a lot of my life and just how you know
the first memories I have are just of
being afraid of stuff you know I
remember my father was you know
obviously I'm not gonna say again how
old my father was always say it but one
of my first memories was I remember
walking I woke up at night and I walked
into this other room in our house and my
sister was real sick you know she was
born with her rare disease and she
needed a transplant and my father was
like rocking her in this rocking chair
and he was crying and he was real sad
you know and uh and I knew that my
sister was sick and I saw him crying and
it just like you know I don't know it
just made me real scared
it made me scared out of the beginning
but yeah I've written some stuff about
that I've written some funny stories and
I think as I get a little bit more
settled after I get done tour in next
year I'm gonna try to focus a little bit
more on getting back to some writing
creating some fun stuff that's not
touring as much because this touring
takes a lot out of me right now and then
one more from fade divorce shack what
books or movies have had an impact on
the way you think about things what was
going on in your life at the time that
you read or saw them and how do they
change your thinking oh wow I don't know
about some of that as deep
what books or movies you know I like
that movie on Bridges of Madison County
you know there's just a moment of choice
in there a moment of love a moment of
comfort you know it just shows how
people's lives can interact and they're
not really you know how every decision
you make isn't so well it just shows
that you can get love in different
places and that there's different levels
to love and different parts of love some
love you get from here and some love you
get from there so I liked that movie
Bridges of Madison County and it's about
bridges and man bridges you know because
think about this before bridge is what
people had to try and jump over
something so if you wanted to get a
message to somebody across the whatever
water you know or whatever dragon area
you had to [ __ ] get a buddy feed him
a bunch of steaks and everything train
him you know get him a rose or a couple
rosaries you know tell him he was gonna
make it and then send him out there
running and the dragon got him you know
I'm saying so bridges or everything
bridges are really because before that
you had to get wet or get eaten or get
burnt
I mean bridges name you know name 11
other things that are better than that
over time maybe and you know and
everybody did a bridge that wasn't a
just a no Benjamin Franklin hogging all
the you know oh be Frankie hogging all
the damn
inventions everybody did a bridge been
so sorry I don't certainly got upset
about that but that's [ __ ] kind of you
know a lot of times all these old people
that is put you know you know Einstein
[ __ ] who else what's that guy's name
mizerock Steve misery
yeah all these people say they invented
everything Thomas Jefferson TJ and oh
yeah you guys did it all but no
everybody did bridges but I love to get
more deeper into that one another time
favorite thank you for that question
about you know what things were going on
in your life at the time you read or saw
them
I don't remember that's you know my
brain doesn't work like that my memory
is not that strong in that sense but
thank you for your support and that is
definite one of my favorite movies and
books and now that Bridges of Madison
County that's word for word book moving
from movie and the Patriot as always he
knows one of my favorite movies ever and
probably always will be aim small miss
small I can't solve a big problem but I
could solve this little small one and
that'll give me the next little small
gang gang man let's get you a couple of
calls that came in because I'm about to
go get lunch on word hold on okay gang
gang with socio gang gang brother
homework man I love you bro since your
uh your show in New York City you did a
really great job made my birthday really
special you know well thank you man I
appreciate that yeah that Club I don't
think that they did a good job they
tried to hurry the VIP you know the meet
and greets and hurry it up at the end of
the show they were flashing the lights
on us you know I don't know up him and
hopefully everybody's experience was
great but you know the guy they it
definitely was in you know it was
I hope you guys his experience was good
I'll just leave it at that because yeah
they're just the music just things that
you know or basic things it didn't seem
like they cared that much about the
people coming to the shows but it's a
Time Square business down there in Times
Square and it's just you know they're
just running people it felt like a diner
where they did comedy yet but um but I
appreciate everybody that came let's
hear more man sorry I was being a little
negative I met you after the show you
told me that uh you know you might have
realized the secret hitters but uh it's
all right man you know there's another
day another dollar and we're out here
and you know I was good for three months
no cigarettes and then I recently also
started again but you know we'll put
some hitters you know and you just got
to try again and try again until you
know they say the success gets better
the more times you do in the longer days
that you've you know been often things
once again I appreciate it oh yeah I've
been Monday's podcast yeah thanks man
yeah I got back on them cigarettes about
a week ago and so some of it is I'll
just get so tired and just so exhausted
it's like I just don't have anything I
can't sleep
Saturday night I couldn't sleep I was up
all night dude I never been up all night
since I was I don't even know since I
probably had colic or something as a
child or if there was a snake in the
room I could never sleep if there was a
snake in the room but uh but yes I've
been back on them ribs man gang home
word remember last Monday's podcast I
wanted to ask you you know like you're
talking about your dad and stuff and
your feelings you know there's a
relationship there I mean do you think
you'd be a different comedian if you had
if you were a father yourself you know
that's a good question would I be a
different comedian if I were a father
myself you know it's funny sometimes I
think I'm afraid to get into a family
and that sort of thing because it'll
change the way that I see the world a
little bit and I'll just want to make
sure I get everything out of the way I
see the world right now
or yeah are well have anything to joke
about them will I just be something you
know such a Nemo Nemo I'll turn into a
damn emo sharp you know and then I'll
just be you notice holding my son just
crying I'm like the bank of a river all
the time like you know I just so I start
to wonder like yeah I just I don't know
it's like I'm I'm kind of at a little
bit at a place from comfortable you know
I'm that comfort cat and so I don't know
if ha you know it gets scary for me to
think oh well if I have a family am I
still gonna be able to be okay
because I don't want to damage them
either you know I don't want to damage
you know I don't want to you know I
don't want to mess up you know I don't
want to mess up some little kid's life
or you know shoot I don't want to create
single moms
that's not trying to do so but that's a
good question man I appreciate you
calling man as always the hot law in
ninety five six six four nine five zero
three let's take another call here hey
oh this is Christie from at last hey
Chrissy from Atlanta thank you for
calling I appreciate you calling from
that ATL I heard your podcast about how
you felt like you used to be maybe
ashamed of your father and I wanted to
say you know my dad was never really a
fancy guy in Atlanta everyone's that go
to golf clubs all the time oh yeah they
got a lot of fancy people over there I
know who you're talking about
I know exactly what you're talking about
the fancy home word everyone's dads are
buying new cars and that's just kind of
how dads are here my dad's from Ecuador
so he is always just he does not care at
all what he what he looks like or
anything but it really for me I felt
like it made me more of a proud person
and like realize what happiness was much
more because instead of golfing and
buying cars my dad was like building
bombs and blowing them up in the
backyard making kayaks out of wood you
know collecting abandoned TVs and you
like using the screens to make flyers in
the back you know just doing a wizardry
it sound like you took my some real
wizardry but no I know you're talking
about it's like you got to see more of a
creative type of dad instead of you know
a lot of times and this does happen in a
lot with a lot of tradition in different
communities I find that people just live
into these streams of tradition and they
don't create their own kind of canals of
creativity a lot of times it sounds like
your father was definitely doing you
know we're doing a little bit more
creativity in creativity you get to see
who someone is you get to see some of
the colors of them oh we're doing cool
stuff and for me that that was actually
a better way to grow up and so I'm like
I'm grateful for that you know but
thanks yeah
well it sounds like yeah it sounds like
you got to have a unique experience with
your dad
yeah it's um it's so weird to it's like
you know we just don't realize some
stuff when were young and sometimes we
realize it later you know we don't know
and that's life isn't it man it's like
you played a lot of the game and then
like years later you kind of get to
watch the game back and review how it
went and it's always feels like that
it's so hard to get to get I don't know
it's so hard to get where you're we're
who you are and the way you feel about
life matches up in real time with what's
going on and maybe some of that just
comes with time and age let's take
another call here thank you for that
call young lady I said math and rodeo
what's up REE dude rodeo I've been
thinking about rodeo that's crazy that
you called man I've been thinking
the rodeo boy I like going to the rodeo
seeing those Wranglers seeing that hat
seeing him buckle see them yeah them
steeds arriving bucking horses saddle
bronc riding horses hell yeah dude
saddle broncs amazing it's like heaven
ah it's like learning to drive like
we're each first learn to drive a
stick-shift but in a [ __ ] f-15 Tomcat
onward I've been to a lot of rodeos
cross country what not knowing about 20
years old so I get along a long last
time a rodeo left but it's kind of hard
to do that and go in this going through
college
I'm a sophomore this year and at the
Fresno State University nice man
congratulations on your sophomore ship
man you getting it done homeward and in
between classes man I set up my schedule
weird so I got a lot of breaks in
between my classes and I listen their
podcast and the king of thing and a
buzzing the thing and whatnot
King this thing's pretty funny brother
that was such a goofy and we just goof
around in their homeward
I would smell them and man I wouldn't I
would be lying if I said I didn't get my
hairstyle after you I got a little bit
of a rat tail PG brother praise God PTL
baby praise the Lord and my brother's
got that rat tail - man Kim and I had a
full mullet but I decided to go and like
kind of a mohawk and leave the tail on
the back I'm kind of set with gin or who
everyone's the submissions Department
for the Candace thing
I've been in a video a few weeks back
and frickin I don't know if chin filters
through all the other cool videos that
they stand in and he takes the matter
what non-black my didn't get in there
and I didn't watch it for a week or so
so I was kind of set one to see how you
guys react to talking about the videos
and whatnot
well you know what I'll see if I can
talk to them over there and see if we
can't get that through because I'd love
to think about the rodeos
and I think that's a great topic man and
gang gang and I appreciate you sending
that in bro
and you know it's so funny when I was in
New York City man I met a police officer
and he his hair his is his horse had a
haircut same as mine and I said is that
your horse and he said yeah yeah that's
my horse I'm on it and so I figured you
know probably was his and then I said
well who cut his hair
and he kind of looks around he's like ah
I'll be honest I kind of [ __ ] it up
I didn't think he was gonna be him man
but I appreciate that honesty and the
horse looked a little shy you know like
you know like people you know like he
had gotten kind of a rough cut man he
needed like he needed a little bit more
comfort cotton on his body
next week we'll do a special Mother's
Day episode I gotta go
and I'm sorry that we're late this week
I'm really excited to be coming over to
Europe I can't even believe this man
like I'm saying things that are like
dreams come true and now I'm saying I'm
like they're just regular things so
maybe I just need it's a sign I've seen
to watch my ego my ego could be getting
weird you know the ego is so dangerous
man
so dangerous huh so I'm grateful this
week I don't have to go anywhere I can
just spend some time kind of uh
trying to think about other people than
myself you know man I get tired of
myself you know I'm grateful but man I
get tired you know I just it's weird the
only way that I really can feel feel
good at a core place at like a place
that you know like in the center like in
my a quarter you know in my like mother
the core of my aortas man is uh is if
I'm able to do something for somebody
else I think that's the only way that
humanity war that we work you know I
don't know what the hell do I know but
be good to yourselves man I know that
you guys deserve it I mean so many so
many people from this from this podcast
and I'm out on the road and
and it's an honor you know it's an honor
and for the people that I don't get to
meet we'll meet you next time
I know some of the IP tickets are sold
out for different places I'll do some
just meet and greets after for everybody
we'll figure it out okay we'll figure it
out and thank you guys for being good to
me I appreciate it and be good to
yourselves don't forget those flowers
from others they are something a card
anything
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far from my
home and my mind is somewhere else but
when I found it our ketchup where it's
been grown now I'm just floating on the
breeze and I feel up full and like these
leaves that must be oh but when I reach
that round I'll share this peace of mind
I can feel it in the palm but it's gonna
take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]
moving way too fast on the runaway train
with a heavy level of man
[Music]
and these whales that are better I know
they want so this template damn they
found out they built a leg
[Music]
makes him some word I came away